see graph yes and we can play maybe I'll
play blitz I'll play blitz white Jetta
and now we have letters it's not the oh
wow we have like a Oh almost have a
bingo like with rejoices I played juice
juice the choice is a word we're playing
a version where there's no wait rejoice
no it can work I want to use all my
letters here and mix it up a little bit
conjoin no I'm not looking at the chat
people can tell me what I missing after
I look at the chat jus juciest I could
just pass and hoping he plays an e I'm
gonna pass such a bad play okay now at
least I have rejoices choice it's
probably best to play it here in Joyce's
okay so we both start the game with
using our all of our letters I guess I
started the game by passing okay my
rating my readings 1585 I'm playing
lowered player-controlled is a good word
for the twitch chat tickle tickle
monster but never mind
I'm sorry tagging it'll be brief this is
a blitz Keane let's play moss I'll play
something with like tickler oh this is
blitz I have to move faster let's play
mer mer is a word okay I have Asus
Oasis these are not the best letters
there's also a word it's a Hawaiian
plant a lie
or no I don't have the letters though
you know another eye for that where can
i play aces it also helps to know the
two letter words like a a is a two
letter word I think it means lava
the thing about Scrabble is you don't
really need to know the the definition
you just need to know that words exists
you've so I'm Lou oh it's 159 man
I still have Oasis but that that would
use both s's Qi is a word I'm very low
on time already
q is is a word nowhere really to play it
what do I do here on get rid of the Q
and use a J somewhere this is difficult
oh man
Oh stickler well I have ticklers - I
could play Qi us and stickler it's
probably a really bad play it is I'm
opening up the queue to the the triple
Lane the hope is that my opponent
doesn't have an eye or a you and if
opponent doesn't then I can play qat
it's a it's a cat like cat and dog it's
one of the few words without a with a Q
not followed by oh you so I'm still
behind but only by four points okay Oh
what to do what to do
not sure what to do here gee I want to
still use a J okay opponent ins score
that much I could play Yolo is a word
maybe no let's play um something here
toy
yeah it really helps to know all the two
letter words I have stony sto and why
hmm well what just happened
keeps doing weird things I could play
Twila Gannon yes toy or and yet for 21
points I've taken the lead to 22 207 I
forty eight seconds but that's okay I
want to play like hmm Oh opponent
exchanged having trouble with like the
oh my keeps doing that job
I'll Lib is a libel word ok libs a word
I was for 11 points so I'm extending my
lead pretty sure ye TT is a word play
like yet and dot opponent took that
spots I could play Jose and slot snorts
and ago okay what do I have is flanger
the word landed handled something land
Madden okay Madden as a word 288 so I
still have my lead I have 20 seconds if
I run out of time I lose 10 points and
then I have 1 more minutes to make the
rest of my my moves okay I'm gonna play
a small EF for 23 points
f is a spelling of letter of the letter
F oh man Dax Oh wanted took the lead
can i play play something hi and maybe
this is not good but I do have the lead
there's seven tiles in the bag
well there's one blink in the bag and
the Z left I want to play win and we
next win for the win
what else can i play view ok we 5
seconds left
I'm gonna play foul or foil or why no
why no and something I could play why
knowing of I still have a lead opponent
has a Z and the blank most likely be
very very careful I'm gonna lose 10
points too very soon okay oh maybe I
won't lose on time
oh I want to play air somewhere air
where can I play air a liar liar can go
there or where's my other play not
seeing it good liar I get it I got it
yes one second left as intense as para
word Oh para yeah parrot but that would
only use I&R it would leave me with an A
okay gain some rating points yeah I feel
like such a new rated under 1600 but
that's the nature of transitioning from
from chess to Scrabble atrocious time
management no it was perfect time
measurements I I took enough time to
find right moves I I didn't flag